[Music]
now we want to talk about who comprises
babylon in these last days so we had
physical babylon back then but the bible
speaks about a babylon in the book of
revelation who comprises babylon and
what is their aim
if you go to revelation 18
now revelation 18 so in revelation 14 we
read verse 8
we have revelation 14 8 all good
advocates should know that what does
that verse say and they followed another
angel saying what babylon
uh
because she made all nations drink of
the wine of her
fornication now
the sex says babylon is fallen now the
fall is not complete it's a progressive
fall
but when that message was given that
message was given after 1798 this is an
end time message this was not given
hundreds and hundreds of years ago this
is since 1798 that this message was uh
given now so it's an end time message
along with the angel of verses uh six
and seven and the angel of nine through
twelve
so this is a message for the end time
now this could not refer only to the
payable system because the people system
has been fallen for hundreds and
hundreds of years and so babylon must
include all the protestant churches that
have compromised and adopted a large
degree the people system or the catholic
system if i can be more blunt and so
babylon is a combination of false
worship system of which the roman church
is the largest contributor and all other
churches in professionally
protestantism have uh surrendered to
actually there was a meeting a few years
ago between catholics and protestants
and some prominent either catholic or
protestants said that revelation the
reformation is over the refuge the
reformation is done this is an evidence
of the fallen condition of babylon and
so babylon refers to a false system of
worship which includes protestantism
apostate protestants i should say and of
course the roman the roman system so
that is babylon and the fall is not yet
complete you see because god still has
people in babylon
and so he called them out in revelation
18 come out of her my people and so that
fault is not yet complete because god
still has some people in there but as a
general system
babylon which refers to false systems of
worship
they have fallen very very far and why
do i say a protestantism if you fall
you've got to fall from somewhere you
fall from a height you never fall up you
fall down when lucifer fell he fell from
above he was cast down
before he fell he occupied an exalted
position protestantism during the time
of the reformation in the 16th century
they were very much in favor with god
because they were opposing entrenched
era they did not know everything because
martin luther never kept the sabbath but
he was still a child of god they did not
know everything but they knew that the
system under which they they were
brought up was false and so in its early
beginnings protestantism pleased god but
after centuries have passed
protestantism have a lot has aligned
itself with the people system and in
doing that protestantism is fallen is
fallen is still falling and it's become
a major part of babylon
amen and i hope we're seeing that
connection product protestantism fell
because it began to intermix or we can
intermarry with deception with the
papacy getting back to those doctrines
that they had left off because they were
ungodly so friends god calls us to be
separate and just to be clear remember
the first question we understood that
babylon originally its origins it's a
physical place that was built by nimrod
who did so in rebellion to god and in
these last days spiritual babylon
represents those are in rebellion to the
word of god namely the papacy and
apostate protestantism so we we we see
that god use physical babylon as a
symbol of spiritual babylon which i
would say is even greater in these last
days let's go to genesis chapter 11
let's uh continue on babylon genesis 11
we read from verse 4
from verse 1.
all right do we have that
yes and the whole earth was in one
language and one speech and it came to
pass as they journeyed from the east
that they found a plane where in the
land of china and they dwelt there and
they said once another go to let us make
brick and burn them thoroughly so they
had breakfast stone and slime and there
for morty and they said go to let us
build this a city and a tower will stop
may raise under heaven and let us make
us a name lest you be scattered abroad
upon the face of the whole earth it was
god's will that mankind would occupy the
entire world the builders of babel did
not want to do that so they stated their
opposition to god's will god's will was
replenish the earth that's what he told
adam he also told moses noah the same
thing in genesis 9.
they refused that they wanted to
concentrate and so they said let us make
us a city build a city in a tower and
let us make us a name lester be
scattered abroad they opposed the will
of god and the lord came down to see the
city and the tower which the children of
men build it god had to come down look
at it and then of course he pronounced
judgment on it verses 6 and 7 of genesis
11. and so we see flagrant opposition to
god not opposition born of ignorance but
flagrant opposition to god's system so
that we have some more introductory
material about babylon and this is the
same people who we read about in chapter
10 whose kingdom was babel eric
babel eric akkid and kalni in the land
of china led by this infamous person
called nimrod flagrant opposition to
god's system
religious
the fact that something is religious
doesn't make it good they have their
religion don't misunderstand me the
canaanites had their religion the
moabites had their religion but god was
not favorable to any of those religions
he gave the true religion to the hebrews
or to the jews or to the israelites so
the po the problem isn't the problem
isn't uh religion in the sense is it is
it consistent with thus said the lord
and babylon's religious system is
diametrically opposed to god's system
even though in many aspects it looks
familiar and so babylon is satan's
chosen instrument for promoting and
popularizing a system of worship that is
contrary to god's system
amen amen
you